اعلنت القوات الروسيه سيطره على موقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه ليمان واشارت
وزاره الدفاع الى ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
استهداف مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه في
كوبيانس حيث شنت المروحيات المقاتله ضربات
على مواقع لتجمع للقوات الاوكرانيه كما
تواصل القوات الروسيه هجومها على امريكا
عبر اطلاق قاذفه من طراز جراد 21 بي ام
في غضون ذلك قال السلطات مقاطعه دونيسك
المواليه لروسيا ان قصفا مدفعيا اوكرانيا
استهدف مستودعا لمصنع لتجهيز الاغذيه في
كويبيشكي بمدينه دوناتسك
مصادر ذاتها الى ان الق
صف امراه وتضرر عدد من المباني كما صادف
روضه للاطفال بمدينه مكيفكا دون سقوط
ضحايا
معنى من دونيسك مراسله الجزيره نور الدين
الدغير نور الدين
ماذا في تفاصيل الهجوم بزورقين مسيرين
اوكرانيين في البحر الاسود كما ذكرت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
نعم حسن يبدو ان هذه المنطقه وهي منطقه
شبه جزيره القرم والبحر الاسود اصبحت احدى
النقاط المهمه للهجوم الذي تقوم به القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه القوات الروسيه لكن ما
حدث وهو ان الهجوم الذي نفذته القوات
الاوكرانيه عبر مسيرات مائيه لم تتمكن من
خلالها من استهداف السفينه الحربيه
الروسيه بل تم استهداف الزورقين وتدميرهما
بحسب وزاره الدفاع الدفاع الروسيه وتتحدث
على ان الهجوم كنا فاشله لكن حسن هذا
الهجوم لا يمكن فصله عن سياق كما اسلفت
سابقا عن سياق ان تكون شبه جزيره القرم
والبحر الاسود منطقه جديده للعمليات
الاوكرانيه امس كان هناك استهداف لشبه
الجزيره بطائرات مسيره هناك كذلك استعمال
لاحدث الصواريخ التي توصلت بها اوكرانيا
وهي ستورم شادو باستهداف جزيره القرم اذا
يمكن القول بان ما يحدث الان اوكرانيا
بهذه المناطق ربما هو استراتيجيه جديده
ربما لاقحام القوات الروسيه او لاضعاف
مجال تحرك القوات الروسيه هناك منطق اساسي
ربما تتحرك عليه القوات الاوكرانيه الان
باستهداف السفن بمحاوله استهداف السفن
الروسيه داخل البحر الاسود ربما هذا لا
ينفصل بشكل او باخر عن مساله صفقه الحبوب
التي توقفت روسيا عن تنفيذها وتعلن اليوم
عبر وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه وعبر نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه بانه لا توجد هناك
اي مفاوضات حاليه قائمه ما بين روسيا وما
بين الاطراف الاخرى سواء الامم المتحده
تركيا او اي جهات اخرى من اجل اعاده تفعيل
هذه الاتفاقيه هناك موقف صريح كذلك يتحدث
على ان تنفيذ هذه الاتفاقيات دون وجود
روسيا لا يمكن ان يتحقق ربما من هذا الباب
يتحرك الجانب الاوكراني من اجل الضغط على
التواجد العسكري التواجد الامني بالبح
الاسود ربما الهدف الاساسي منه ربما هكذا
تفهم روسيا وهي فتح ممرات للسفن
الاوكرانيه للعبور وربما اكثر من ذلك وهي
محاوله الضغط على روسيا ضمن شبه جزيره
القرم ربما الهدف الاساسي وهو ضرب مواقع
الذخيره مواقع الدعم والاسناد للقوات
الروسيه بهذه المنطقه وهناك من يتحدث على
ان اوكرانيا ربما تحاول من خلال هذه
العمليات جس النبض الروسي من اجل ربما
القيام بمرحله ثانيه بخطه الهجوم المضاده
التي اعلنت في وقت سابق من دونات مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين الدغير شكرا لك